[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend die sportlichen Neuigkeiten
später wieder mit Katja Stresow mit
einigen Erfolgsmeldungen schönen guten
Abend und hier sind unsere Themen an
diesem Sonntag
Korruptionsvorwürfe die EU will Ungarn
Zahlungen in Höhe von 7,5 Milliarden
Euro streichen
[Musik]
letzte Vorbereitungen einen Tag vor dem
Staatsbegräbnis der Queen versammeln
sich hochrangige Gäste aus aller Welt in
London
und Sprung ins Glück Gold für das
deutsche Team bei der Vielseitigkeit WM
in Italien
[Musik]
das einheits- und werteprinzip der EU
wird durch Länder wie Ungarn seit Jahren
hart auf die Probe gestellt Brüssel
plant deswegen jetzt einen einmaligen
Schritt gegen Budapest der Vorwurf
mangelnde Rechtsstaatlichkeit deswegen
will die EU-Kommission Ungarn die
Haushaltsmittel kürzen zwischen 2021 und
27 bekommt Ungarn laut Kommission
mindestens 50 Milliarden Euro aus einem
Teil davon den strukturfördermitteln
will Brüssel jetzt etwa 7,5 Milliarden
streichen ein Grund die EU-Gelder seien
im Land von Regierungschef Orban nicht
ausreichend vor Missbrauch geschützt und
Korruption weit verbreitet mehr von
Isabel Schäfers
Sechser südliches Ungarn hier lebt der
freie Abgeordnete arcorsch hat Hasi der
immer wieder Korruptionsfälle aufdeckt
auch in seiner Stadt seien etwa bei der
Auftragsvergabe für neue Straßenlaternen
öffentliche Gelder verschwendet worden
immer wieder auch EU-Mittel wir möchten
dass wir diese Geld ja nur dann bekommen
sollten wenn mit dieser Erde der
Ministerpräsident nicht seine Leute
bezahlen könnte auch die EU-Kommission
will verhindern dass EU-Gelder in Ungarn
missbraucht werden etwa durch Korruption
sie schlägt deshalb vor rund 7,5
Milliarden Euro EU-Mittel einzubehalten
eine Premiere zwar hatte Ungarn bis
zuletzt Reformen angekündigt um das zu
verhindern aber der EU-Kommission reicht
das bisher nicht
Severin schwerere von der Kommission
ermittelten Probleme erfordern nicht nur
Änderungen des Rechtsrahmens sondern
auch konkrete Maßnahmen in der Praxis
dies erfordert mehr Zeit daher geht die
Kommission davon aus dass derzeit weiter
ein Risiko den EU-Haushalt besteht
aus Ungarn heißt es heute wieder man sei
bereit alle Verpflichtungen gegenüber
der EU-Kommission einzuhalten von Seiten
der EU-Kommission wurde heute auffällig
stark betont dass man jetzt vor allem
die konkrete Umsetzung der bereits
vorgeschlagenen Maßnahmen von Ungarn
erwarte das soll zeigen die
EU-Kommission greift durch man hält den
Druck aufrecht aber am Ende könnte doch
wieder ein Kompromiss stehen und die
einbehaltenen Mittel an Ungarn
ausgezahlt werden ob die Gelder
tatsächlich einbehalten werden müssen
die Mitgliedstaaten entscheiden
voraussichtlich im Dezember bis dahin
hat Ungarn noch Zeit gegenzusteuern
das britische Verteidigungsministerium
hat vor zunehmenden Angriffen Russlands
auf zivile Ziele in der Ukraine gewarnt
Moskau wolle damit vermutlich die Moral
des ukrainischen Volkes untergraben
Ukraine ist Präsident silensky sprach
von neuen Hinweisen auf Folter in von
Russland verlassenen Gebieten in der
Region hakif sein mehr als 10
Folterkammern gefunden worden
Niedersachsens Ministerpräsident weil
fordert zur Finanzierung von
Entlastungen die Schuldenbremse
auszusetzen man sei in einer Notlage so
der SPD-Politiker zuvor schon hatte
Bayerns Ministerpräsident Söder
Widerstand gegen das dritte
Entlastungspaket angekündigt es sei so
keinesfalls zustimmungsfähig Grund die
Kostenaufteilung zwischen Bund und
Ländern ähnlich äußerten sich auch die
Länderchefs in Sachsen-Anhalt und Bremen
Briefe die verloren gehen zu spät kommen
oder im falschen Briefkasten landen ein
Problem das offenbar immer mehr Deutsche
betrifft laut Bundesnetzagentur ist die
Zahl der Beschwerden deutlich gestiegen
etwa 6.500 seien allein im Juli und
August eingegangen die Post hat eine
einfache Erklärung dafür der
Fachkräftemangel und die
Personalausfälle durch Corona
das Begräbnis von Königin Elisabeth II
gilt vielen schon jetzt als jahrhundert
Ereignis gekrönte Häupter Würdenträger
und Staatschefs aus aller Welt werden
ihr morgen die letzte Ehre erweisen
unter ihnen auch Bundespräsident
Steinmeier über die logistische
Herausforderung für Sicherheitsbehörden
wartende Trauergäste und die
angereistete Prominenz jetzt Lück
wahlbot
der amerikanische Präsident beiden und
seine Frau reiten sich am Nachmittag ein
in den langen Trost der Trauernden die
am Sarg der Queen kondolieren zur
Beisetzung morgen werden mehr als 100
Starts und Regierungschefs aus aller
Welt erwartet Kaiser naruito von Japan
und seine Frau gehören dazu ebenso wie
Bundespräsident Steinmeier für die
Sicherheitskräfte in London ist es eine
riesen Herausforderung neben den
Monarchen Staats- und Regierungschefs
werden morgen auch mehr als eine Million
Besucher erwartet
mandai Montag wird der größte und wohl
auch komplexeste Einsatz den wir je
hatten
die kilometerlange Warteschlange zum
aufgebahrten Sarg wurde am Nachmittag
geschlossen bis morgen früh soll so
allen die sich hier eingereiht haben
auch Einlass gewährt werden am 35
Kilometer entfernten Schloss Windsor wo
die Königin morgen beigesetzt werden
soll versammeln sich inzwischen viele
tausende um Abschied von ihr zu nehmen
ich empfinde unglaubliche Trauer der
Verlust schmerzt er hat mich sehr
getroffen
für mich war das auf jeden Fall das Ende
einer Ära sie hat so lange regiert 70
Jahre
zur Stunde treffen die geladenen
Staatsgäste im Buckingham Palast ein
darunter auch der frühere spanische
König Juan Carlos sie wurden von König
Charles dem dritten zu einem Empfang
geladen
also das wird ein Mega Event morgen in
London Andreas Stamm was kommt da auf
die Sicherheitsbehörden zu
ja wie es im Beitrag angeklungen ist
etwas was diese Stadt so noch nicht
gesehen hat auch durch die Jahrhunderte
nämlich die größte sicherheitsoperation
die es je gegeben hat es sind ja eben
diese 100 Staatsgäste mehr als das da
sind Würdenträger da sind ja Kaiser
Könige dabei und die zu schützen ist
natürlich eine unglaubliche
Herausforderung und für Sicherheit
Sicherheitsexperten ein Albtraum denn
man muss sich auch vorstellen bei der
Prozession des Sargs sind dann ja
vielleicht eine Millionen Menschen an
den Seiten Rändern und die sind nur
wenige Meter entfernt vom König von der
königlichen Familie und da gibt es
keinen Schutz dazwischen also das muss
man sagen wird sehr sehr sehr sehr ernst
genommen hier aber auf der anderen Seite
erstens 10.000 Polizisten 1500 ja freie
Helfer von Sicherheitsfirmen und
freiwillige und 1500 Soldaten die auf
Abruf bereitstellen zweitens die
britischen Behörden gelten als mit die
besten in der Welt wenn es darum geht
solche Massen Events zu bewältigen und
drittens ja für diesen Tag wurde
jahrelang geprobt er wurde jahrelang
geplant und der Organisator der Chef für
diese sicherheitsoperation der Londoner
polizeischiffe noch mal klar gemacht man
sei auf alles vorbereitet und man sei
auf alles bestens vorbereitet dann danke
für die Information aus London Andreas
Stamm und zu den Ereignissen in London
noch diese Hinweise ab 21:45 Uhr im
heute-journal ein Interview mit
Bundespräsident Steinmeier der schon in
London ist und die dortigen
Trauerfeierlichkeiten wird das ZDF
morgen ab 9 bis 18 Uhr live übertragen
heftige Szenen erreichen uns aus Taiwan
dort hat ein Erdbeben der Stärke 6,8
schwere Schäden angerichtet nahe Taipeh
spielten Menschen in einer Sporthalle
gerade Badminton als ihnen die Decke
entgegenkam und die durch ein Wunder gab
es nur einen leicht verletzten im
Südosten der Insel nahe des Epizentrums
stürzten ganze Häuser ein in den
Trümmern suchen Einsatzkräfte nach
Verschütteten ein Mensch kam bislang ums
Leben
wir sind jetzt beim Sport und Katja und
guten Nachrichten vom Basketball aus
denn die deutsche
Basketball-Nationalmannschaft hat gerade
eben bei der Heim ihr Spiel um Bronze
gewonnen in Berlin gegen Polen
überzeugte das Team von Gordon Herbert
für zu Halbzeit mit 13 Punkten nach
einer Schwächephase im dritten Viertel
geht am Ende der Kapitän voran Dennis
Schröder entscheidet die Partie mit zwei
drei Jahren Deutschland feiert ein Happy
End gewinnt 82 69 und damit die
bronzeilen das Finale zwischen
Frankreich und Spanien dann heute Abend
jetzt zur Fußball-Bundesliga der Union
Berlin wieder die Tabellenführung
übernommen hat denn im ersten
Sonntagsspiel besiegten die Berliner
Wolfsburg mit 2:0 die Wölfe dadurch
jetzt auf Rang 17 und jetzt noch zu
einem goldenen Sonntag für Deutschlands
Vielseitigkeitsreiter denn die IT mit
Julia Krajewski Sandra Auffahrt Michael
Jung und Christoph Wahler hat bei den
Weltmeisterschaften in Italien verdient
Mannschaftsgold geholt und auch im
Einzel kam noch eine Medaille hinzu
nämlich Silber für Julia kajewski
die glorreichen vier die deutsche Equipe
auf der Ehrenrunde mit weltmeisterlich
großem Abstand vor den USA und
Neuseeland
Olympiasiegerin Julia Krajewski bringt
mir die ramonte benevil das Team
entscheiden nach vorne ihr gelingt mit
einem null Fehler wird das Kunststück im
Einzel von Rang 5 noch auf den zweiten
Platz zu springen nur getoppt von der
Britin Jasmine und Bonsai Dua ihr erstes
großes Championat und gleich Gold
dekoriert denn Michael Jung dem
Doppel-Weltmeister von 2010 unterläuft
mit seinem Wallach Chipmunks am letzten
Sprung jener Fehler der in Gold kostet
und auf Platz 5 zurückwirft
überraschende einzelweltmeisterin die 25
Jahre alte Britin in Ingelheim doch die
deutsche Mannschaft beschert mit
teamgold dem neuen Bundestrainer Thomsen
einen perfekten wm-einstand
eben hatten wir ein paar Tonprobleme die
wird mir zu entschuldigen jetzt hört man
mich wieder und dich vor allem so wir
werfen auf fix den Blick aufs Wetter im
Südwesten meist freundlicher und trocken
sonst wechseln bewölkt mit vielen
Schauern und kurzen Gewittern bei viel
Wind und 11 bis 17 Grad
Christian Sievers ordnet die
Nachrichtenlage ab 21:45 Uhr im
heute-journal ein wir sehen uns morgen
wieder Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend
und jetzt direkt in die Hauptstadt zu
Schack runterladen und Berlin direkt